did you have any fear that they were
going to pick ari's season
for one of the uh greatest seasons ever
episodes
i ended things with becca i want to take
the risk and see if there's a
possibility with her
i want a second chance i mean
no i just i never really thought that it
would be considered one of the greatest
efforts
to be honest
miss lauren lion dyke i haven't talked
to you in a while it's so good to see
you how are you
i know it's been forever i'm doing so
good how are you
i'm great i i know we're here to talk
about your clothing line
shades of rose so i wore a little a
little shade of rose today and are you
wearing
it i am actually yeah this is one of my
tops that i
made for the line
[Music]
how long had you been working on this i
started working on this about two years
ago
we were supposed to launch back in march
and obviously that's when everything
kind of blew up um so now
we're doing it now so how would you
describe the line to someone if they
asked
um i would say it's a lifestyle brand
and for this protect or particular
collection
it's geared towards being able to dress
it up or down
so i wanted to make sure i was being
sensitive to the climate of
what we're dealing with right now the
price point is going to be
between 40 and 150 so it's very
reasonably priced because i wanted to be
inclusive so that everybody could
buy the pieces if they wanted to um
there's 12 different pieces in this
collection
what does ari think of it has he has he
tried any of the pieces on
i mean i should make him try some on
i've been making him do some
some cross-dressing tick tocks over
according to so how did you arrive at
shades of rose is that a little nod to
the bachelor you'd say it's a little bit
of a nod
but the rose for me is a symbol of
femininity
so it's the shade of rose i do feel like
since
your time on the bachelor we're seeing
these different sides of you that
we didn't necessarily see on the show
like you're doing a clothing line and
you know you guys have your youtube
channel so we're gonna have a little art
project
outside we're gonna paint right yeah
we're gonna paint i want our lassie to
make
us some artwork for the house that we
can hang up i mean i've obviously grown
a lot since the show i think being
thrust
into the spotlight like that is kind of
life-changing in a lot of ways
and for me i've just been forced to get
really comfortable with every
side of myself i think also the show is
really stressful for me because
i really cared about aria a lot from the
beginning and it was hard for me to see
him dating other girls
there was that strong affection towards
her
and yes logically we made more sense
i understand that
i have to ask the tough question but
have you guys talked to becca at all
ever since then
are are things good are they copacetic i
mean
i haven't had any correspondence with
her like we talked to her
right before her finale and that was the
last time but it seems like
overall as well oh yeah yeah everything
is fine i think everyone's moved on by
now
i forgot that you at one point revealed
that you and ari had
briefly met before the show so how did
you wind up going on the ship i met him
at a racetrack
and then three months later a lot of my
friends from virginia they're all
married
and engaged and they're like there's
casting in dallas you have to go this
time this place
just like let us know what it's like so
i was like okay fine i went
and then i just kept making it through
the next round next round
and they actually told me that they
wanted me to be on the show before they
told me who the bachelor was
so they're like you're gonna have to
watch good morning america to find out
who that is
and so i'm watching good morning america
and he walks out on the stage and i'm
like
what like what odds that i meet this guy
the same summer that i'm cast to go on
this show and he was on it like five
years ago
it was just an incredible coincidence
some people are very
against like talking to anybody before
the show where do you fall on that do
you think it's okay or do you say don't
do it just go into the show and have the
experience
i would say definitely don't do it i
mean if you have
if you know you're gonna be the lead i
mean i just don't think it gives the
the contestants a fair chance that are
coming on the show to get to know you if
you're thinking about somebody back home
that's fair and i love you very much
and i want you back
you guys are this success story of the
franchise but
you did face so much backlash when you
were becoming i'm like
i almost wonder if you guys grew even
closer than some other couples might be
because you kind of like
only had each other we say that all the
time
at the times where we felt like the
entire world was against us we had each
other
and like sometimes it felt like that's
all we had so
yeah we got close really quickly and i
feel like we're a really strong couple
because of that
so we filmed our our journey and
although it doesn't have the happiest
outcome i feel like there's
people at home that go through this all
every day how would you say that you
guys did
get through that time and that loss did
you learn new things about each other
how did you lean on each other during
that and did one of you
have to step up more than the other we
really released that video on youtube
about this garage a while back it was
definitely hard for both of us and
with kovid he wasn't able to come with
me to any of my doctor's appointments
so that was a tough thing for him too
because i think
he really wanted to be there for me and
it was hard for him to have to sit in
the
parking lot and not be there obviously i
was going through it physically so it
was really difficult for me but i had to
take a step back and be like
you know he's going through this too so
we learned
a lot about like working together and
you know the give and take of going
through something like that together
he bought you that beautiful ring um
what was your reaction when you got that
from him
um tears just you know
really emotional because that symbolized
something that
was a little you know heartbreaking for
us to go through
yeah so does this feel like
you know does launching this line feel
like some positivity you needed or you
know what i mean is it kind of a good
new chapter to be moving forward with
yeah i think it came at the like it
couldn't have come at a more perfect
time because
i started getting really deep into the
launch of this
when that tragedy happened for us so it
really gave me something to direct my
attention towards
do you plan on releasing more clothing
after this
i'm already working on the next four
collections right now so i'm
i'm dropping this one then there's fall
there's winter
like holiday is what they call it and
then resort and spring
oh resort okay yep
the next four collections that's a lot
yeah oh my gosh how much time have you
spent working on this
a lot like i wake up i wake up at like 5
a.m
and go to bed at 11 every night because
i'm trying to work around my daughter's
nap schedule oh my gosh mama is on it
and what's next for you guys from here
do you plan to try and work on expanding
the family more again
are you focused on the work stuff where
do you kind of see the next year or so
for you
i mean i'm trying to do both at the same
time like this is my
work baby but we would love to have
another real baby too
so that's in the works but it just
hasn't happened yet
well i love hearing that that's in the
works
[Music]